ما الذي ياتي بكم الى هذا المعرض هل من
جديد على صعيد المفاوضات الراميه لبيع
الامارات طائرات بقيمه قيل انها تصل الى
عشره مليارات دولار ما اتى بنا الى هنا
وعلاقتنا القويه مع الامارات وشراكتنا في
العديد من المجالات الدفاعيه وغيرها و
ميادين التعاون بيننا تنمو بما يعكس عمق
الصداقه بين البلدين
ومن بين تلك المجالات بالطبع نناقش
التعاون حول العديد من المعدات الدفاعيه
وسنواصل هذه المفاوضات التي نحقق فيها
تقدما جيدا جدا هل حمل تم رسائل تطمين دول
الخليج ال قلقه حيال التقارب الاخيره بين
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا من جهه وايران
من جهه اخرى
كلنا نبحث عن تحقيق الهدف عينه في المنطقه
والمتمثل في السلام والاستقرار فلا احد
منا يريد رؤيه تداعيات سعي ايران الى
امتلاك سلاح نووي او حصول نزاع في المنطقه
ولذلك نحن نقوم ب افضل ما يمكننا لتجنب
حصول هذه السيناريوهات ونتحدث مع
الايرانيين لمعرفه مدى جديتها واشدد على
ذلك في البحث عن حل سلمي لخلافهم النووي
مع العالم ويجب على اصدقائنا في الخليج لا
يكون لديهم ادنى شك باننا سنقف الى جوارهم
وان صداقتنا معهم ستكون المعيار الذي يحدد
تحركاتنا هل تحدث من دول الخليج عن
الموضوع السوري الذي يقول البعض انه بات
يقتصر على السلاح الكيماوي نناقش الموضوع
السوري على الدوام خلال زيارتنا الى
المنطقه فهو من بين المواضيع الاقليميه
الحساسه والقول بان القضيه باتت تقتصر على
الموضوع الكيماوي امر غير صحيح ف نحن
مهتمون بالكارثه الانسانيه الموجوده كما
اننا معنيون بايجاد حل سياسي كفيل بانهاء
النزاع في سوريا
وايضا نحن مهتمون بشكل كبير لضمان منع
نظام الاسد من استخدام السلاح الكيماوي
والعمل على تدميره ونحن نحقق تقدما جيدا
على هذا الصعيد